hi reddit my boyfriend and i have been
dating for a year
and it has been great except for one
thing
dota the other day
on a saturday i was over and he was
playing a game
i thought it would just be one but
instead he proceeded to play for
three hours as i just sat there
what can i do so this as you can see
it is a post from a subreddit called
relationships of someone seeking
relationship advice now i would claim
that this is
clearly fake because no one plays dota
for just three hours
crazy but let's assume that this is a
thing that really happened
and well it doesn't matter the article
here is written
and the task is to summarize this post
in
as few tokens as you can but sort of
giving much of the information that's in
the
that is in the post itself so the task
here is called
summarization and humans can do this
quite well so here you see a human
written uh reference pr uh baseline
my boyfriend games whenever he can how
can i get him to stop
gaming so much and focus more on school
and our relationship
okay so that's a pretty good summary of
what goes on in this model the
most the easiest bass lines for this
task in machine learning are what's
called
extractive bass lines so in extractive
summarization what you do is you try to
find
sub spans so let's say like this span
followed by this span and so on um
that together represent the article so
you strictly
select subspans or even entire
phrases from the text that you're
looking at
so a lot of these baselines are
extractive and they perform already
fairly okay for example uh this one
right here help
my uh my boyfriend is neglecting his
studies
and our relationship because of a video
game i think that's just extracting from
the title
okay that's title policy there are other
models for example here the sleep too hi
reddit my boyfriend and i have been
dating for a year and it has been great
i mean that
accurately represents
maybe not maybe that's not so you can
already see that it's quite hard
um because not only does a model have to
understand what information is in the
text and what are the important things
but also clearly it needs to understand
something about
the intent of the of the post right um
you wanna if you wanna compress you have
to compress the meaning and the meaning
because we are humans we understand that
this person here is distressed
um seeking advice right it's like
what should i do and we understand that
the source of the frustration
is the fact that the boyfriend here
plays a lot of this this video game
it's not really important you know how
much they played or even that they've
been dating for a year
or so on the the problem here
communicated is the playing video games
so
you see that the researchers here have
come up with a bunch of
models and their best model that we're
going to look at here is called
this human feedback model with 6.7
billion
parameters it's a gpt style model and
we'll get to all of this in one second
i'll just want to kind of show you the
end result
that can output the following my
boyfriend is neglecting his studies
and our relationship because of his
excessive gaming of a
video game what can i do to get him to
stop
all right so there are a couple of
nuances here
like the the what can i do to get him to
stop
is not really explicitly said in the
text
it says it seems like it interfered with
our relationship he's doing his phds
obviously swamped
um it goes on the back burner
it makes me rethink our relationship and
so on it these things aren't explicitly
said yet the model somehow understands
that that's what this person expresses
and if you want to compress this then
this information then this is a very
good thing too
this is a very good summary to output so
we'll go to see how they come to build
this model what it has to do with human
feedback
and um just in generally how it works
and also where it fails
so this is a pretty big paper as you can
see it's one of those papers where the
appendix
needs a table of contents which is going
to come up
very shortly very this there there was
um lots of references so it's a paper by
open ai um of course recently
openai has made big big advancements in
language research with gpt three and
this
is from kind of the same style of
research so the paper is called learning
to summarize
from human feedback by nissan stinon
long young daniel m ziegler
ryan lowey chelsea voss alec radford
daario amodai and
paul cristiano as i said of open ai
so they tackle this task of
summarization
of this of these kind of posts or news
articles you can apply this
pretty much anywhere and they
incorporate human feedback into it now
why do they incorporate human feedback
and that's because
that's because summarization isn't a
straightforward
task right so in its basic if you have a
summarization task
you have some sort of a piece of text
that
contains some information and from this
you want to generate a small piece of
text
the small piece of text should be first
very short
but second also it should contain
information
it should contain all the information
that was contained in the original
article
maybe not all of it but it should
contain the important information
of what is in the article and then there
are some other things like
it should also be coherent but
i think that's sort of implicit in this
information objective
what you want to do is if someone reads
this piece of text
they should get all the information
that was in the big text or not all but
most or the important information humans
are quite okay
at this but it's not like we can really
formulate
exactly what we want right it's not like
we can
give a classification label and then
tell the machine
exactly look this class is correct and
these other classes
are wrong now what people have been
doing is they've built data sets
where you'd have for one particular
document
you'd give it to let's say three
different humans
and the three different humans would
produce three different summaries
because different humans do it
differently right
so you'd provide three different
summaries and then
you let your machine your machine
learning model produce
some summary and then your evaluation
metric
would be an a metric that takes this
piece of text and compares it
to those pieces of text and this one of
these methods here is called
rouge so rouge is a metric that looks at
ngram overlap so
the wikipedia page pulled up here and
you can see it consists of a bunch of
sub metrics but there is a way to mix
them
but in their essence they basically look
at
overlaps of here overlap of n grams
so you can look unigrams or bi-grams you
can look longest common
subsequence and so on basically you sort
of
try to compare the words
the text specifically in here to the
texts
in in the human summaries
and given the rich nature of language
that's not really a good approach but
it's the best one we have
like we don't we don't have a better
metric to tell the machine what's right
or wrong
and it goes actually further so this
rouge as an evaluation metric
it's already it's fairly bad
as we can see as we will see they have a
graph somewhere and i might just
draw the graph in that
if this if this here is kind of the the
complexity of the
information and this here is the
how good the summary really is as rated
by humans
so this paper plays a lot of emphasis on
going to actual humans and asking them
how good is a summary if you employ
rouge
then at the beginning you increase as
you increase the
the quality so for easy text
for easy information um and for really
bad models
the rouge metric makes sense because
you know generally if you have a very
crappy model
and one that just outputs the same kind
of text as the humans do then that one's
gonna fare better but
then at some point it wanes off and the
at some
level of complexity coherence and so on
the rouge metric is just
not good enough anymore to differentiate
sorry to differentiate
good from bad summaries or
let's say to differentiate um excellent
from
good but not excellent summaries let's
phrase it like this it's bad it's good
at differentiating bad from good
summaries but not good from excellent
okay so that's one thing that's
evaluation but
rouge this overlap of n grams you can
imagine that this is not differentiable
so the second problem is how do we even
train this thing right
so this here is this is eval
rouge eva but in training
you do something even less um let's say
something even that makes even less
sense from a
just a principled point approach what
you want to do
is you want to simply make the machine
output
these texts right so you simply say
these texts are
correct now please output those it's
kind of like a variational auto encoder
that you wanted to output a very
specific picture but you've
given it that picture as an input you
can kind of
imagine it like this you say this is the
input
and this is the output i want you to
produce
and now that i can actually back
propagate i can back propagate
the production of this exact text
from this input right so their model
here is going to be
some sort of a gpt3 style
model it's not as big as gpt3 their
biggest model
i think is 6 billion seven billion
parameters
whereas gpt3 has what 175 billion
parameters or something like this
so the model is going to work as follows
you take this
text here you just unroll it i think
some like this
so that it's just one string and then
you let the model produce so here's the
model is on top of this
and you simply always produce the next
character or word or word piece
right here and then you produce the next
and you produce the next until you've
output this thing here and this thing
here is going to be
the summary okay
and that's a thing you can back
propagate through with simply language
model learning i'm bragging a bit too
much because
of course many things are trained like
this in language learning like
translation is learned like this
just these simple generative language
models are learned like this
so it's not that terrible but you can
see that evaluating with
rouge while training with this both are
not particularly suited to what we want
what we want
actually is that humans
would rate these summaries well
but we can't do that and that's the
problem that this paper solves
so here they show their final results
already
so down here you have model size but we
we don't worry about that right now that
because there's also
a question of scaling here and so on if
they use
a language model that was just
pre-trained
on language so no terrain no explicit
training for summarization
we've already seen in the gpt2 and gpt3
paper
that if i take a piece of text
and da and i append
the string tl dr
right too long didn't read which in in
forum posts most often people put this
and then they put a summary okay so this
prompts the model to produce a summary
if this seems mysterious to you i've
made videos on gpt2
and gpt3 explaining how this works so a
model that has just been trained
on language modeling will actually be
able to do
summarization to a certain degree as you
can see right here
it's still below the quality of
reference summary so this
axis is really what humans this
wow that body attachment to the legs
um is really what humans think of these
summaries so
the way they evaluate it is they present
the human with two different summaries
they ask them which one do you prefer of
course if you give them
human summaries um
so one of them is always a human summary
but if you give them two human summaries
it's of course random which one they
prefer and therefore
that's uh the 0.5 point
so if you give them one summary from
this pre-trend model and one human
summary you can see that the pre-trained
summary loses most of the time loses
like 80
70 to 80 percent of the time against the
human
reference summary then
the second step is to take this model
and produce what they called a
supervised
baseline so that's what we've discussed
just now when we said how do we even
train this
so we take a model that takes a database
uh sorry a data set i've been some
reviewers are just calling data sets
databases and it
freaks me out and i've taken it over
i've seen it so many times now there
must be
parts of the world where data sets are
called databases
so in this you always you have samples
of um
text and corresponding summary so you
call this your x
and you call this your y and you simply
train a model to take in the x
and predict the y now instead of a
class label it's simply a string a piece
of output
string you can do this with a language
model like a generative language model
that's a that's the supervised baseline
so if they do that
they get closer as you can see right
here so
there is quite a bit of distance between
this pre-trained model
and the supervised baseline
that starts from the pre-trained model
but actually trains the model to do
summarization but you're still not at
the level
of these reference summaries and then
they have this mysterious human feedback
model that now all of a sudden
actually gets better than the reference
summaries it actually
uh outperforms them and
we're going to look at how this comes
about
so first of all their contributions as
they
stated they say we show
that training with human feedback
significantly outperforms very strong
baselines on english summarization
okay we show human feedback models
generalize much better to new domains
than supervised models okay
and we conduct extensive empirical
analyses of our policy and reward model
all right so if you see the words policy
and reward model that already means that
reinforcement learning is going to play
some role here and here's how it works
so this all already starts
from the supervised model so imagine
what you've done so far you have this
pre-trained model
you've taken it you've generated a
supervised
model for it so the supervised model is
explicitly trained to do summarization
but just on a data set and now you want
to
incorporate human feedback okay so the
way you incorporate human feedback is as
follows
first you collect the human feedback and
the human feedback here
you could do various things so you could
let the humans kind of
score summaries but
what you want to do in this case is you
always want to present the human with
two
different summaries and ask them which
one do they prefer
okay that's going to be our humans are
going to be
just doing this thing for now they
are going to look at two summaries and
the corresponding piece of text
that's important and they're going to
decide
which summary is better and better in
just in a human sense better right so
they
they work closely together with the
researchers right here
and that's i think an advantage if
you're open ai and have lots of funding
and so on they
it's it appears they've paid these
humans quite well and they've worked
with them quite closely to in order to
ensure the high quality of their
feedback
so the humans will always say which of
these two summaries is better
okay now what you could imagine is you
could simply train a model
using that right so the model it
produces this
and maybe the human one of the humans
some reason the data set is that
and then the human decides is it better
or worse and then a model somehow
optimizes this
this is not exactly what they do because
that would require too many humans
if you know these language models they
take a lot of data
so even though openai has lots of budget
it's not really feasible for them to
train these big language models
and every single training step for every
single sample go and ask a human
what do you think so they have to come
up with some sort of different
way to do this so what they do is
this entire thing right here
oops this entire thing right here
will now be a data set okay it will be a
new data set
so they take this supervised model and
they produce a whole bunch of these
summaries and they always
ask the humans which one's better so
this will be a data set and the sample
from this data set will consist
of a big text two summaries of that text
and it doesn't really matter how they're
generated just two summaries
and a label and the label is either this
one's better
or this one's better okay so this here
is going to be now our
x and this one is going to be our y
of that data set and to this data set we
now
fit a model so we fit a model
to simulate the human okay we the model
learns from the human in re in
reinforcement learning this is very
related to
imitation learning reward model learning
um there are a bunch of
names for it in this case they they say
we train a reward mode it's actually not
exactly sorry it's not exactly
limitation learning because that there
you'd have actually samples of the
policy
and so on so let's stick with reward
model learning so
that i'm correct the exact way you do
this is you don't actually
fit the x to the y right here but what
they train
is this reward model right here so this
thing takes in
as you can see a piece of text and one
summary
and it predicts a number and the number
is supposed to say
how good is that thing how good is that
summary for that given document
and the humans never said that right so
we can't
directly we can't directly use this as a
label right here
we we cannot because we don't have this
information we just have the information
whether it's better or worse than some
other thing so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the same
article and a different summary of
the um of that poster one post with two
summaries
judged by a human are fed to the reward
model
so this is fed to the same reward model
the same model
gives at the output for that one and
then
we train our loss is going to consist
which one's better
so the loss is pretty simple right here
you simply subtract them from each other
this is a
sigmoid non-linearity and
the log because the loss is in log space
but the
sigmoid right here ultimately what that
does is
if so here's zero if
post j is better than post
k this is going to be a positive number
right
so the sigmoid will map this to a
1 over here if post k
is better than post j the sigmoid will
map it to a
0 right here and if they get close to 0
then something like this right
so in this case here post j is better
and
in this case here post k is better
so that seems like a sensible loss that
you can regress
on so now you map these rewards to a
zero
or a one and that's exactly what your
label is your label is either a zero if
this post is better or a one if this
post
is better so now you have a data set and
you have a model that you can train
namely this model right here so you're
going to train this reward model
on this data set and you can iterate
this
at the end even though we aren't at the
end yet you can go back
and do it all over again if you want and
i think
they do they iterate this improving
their summaries asking the humans again
training reward model and then the last
part is
that you actually now you have a reward
model right
remember we said it was too expensive
for humans to always go
ask the human which one do you prefer
well now we have a
model that can substitute the human so
what we can do is we can simply trade
use
reinforcement learning to train
the summarization model to maximize the
reward
okay so now we give the model this model
right here we give a piece of text and
it produces a summary
remember this
these models are exactly that these
models right here
are exactly these models okay
in fact we start from the supervised
baseline
we plug this in here that's the model
that actually produces the summary
and we are going to fine-tune that using
reinforcement learning
now ppo proximal policy optimization is
a
pretty simple but very effective
reinforcement learning technique
so what you need is you simply need an
input this
your x then you need an action
this going to be our action this is
going to be our output
of the model and then you need a reward
so for the reward you take this model
right here
and this at this point this is fixed so
you learned your reward model now this
is fixed
now you have a model that for each
summary can give you
how good that summary is right this
reward and you can use that to do
reinforcement learning so the
reinforcement learning simply
tries to generate a summary that makes
the reward model as
happy as possible
and the reward model is learned from the
humans so you can see that
at the end through the proxy of the
reward model
we are directly training for human uh
human enjoyment so we are not training
log likelihood like we did initially in
the supervised baseline
we are not training for rouge which we
could do with reinforcement learning
but rouge itself is a pretty bad metric
we are actually training for directly
for what humans say they prefer at least
as far as the reward model can
approximate the human preferences
so you can see that this is potentially
a a good approach now
um this was also kind of if you read
this
stuff in let's say on twitter or
elsewhere
people are people are i think very
joyous that
wow we are aligning
um models with human interest we are
aligning them with human preferences and
so on human in the loop yeah yeah
yeah um it's still
it's still difficult i i think this is
slightly
over hyped in in that direction like the
direction of where we go say wow these
are
uh so these are so such good things
because so first of all
um this costs a lot of money a lot
of money like you need to work closely
together with these humans
right and um i don't know where they say
it
but they actually did not compare
to a model that collected
so if you do this supervised thing right
here
you have your data set right of text
and multiple reference summaries well
okay
no one knows no one knows what happens
if you invest as much
time money and effort into collecting a
bigger data set of simple reference
summaries and then training a supervised
model on that
nobody knows okay so and they they say
this they admit this
in this um in this paper they say we did
not it's too expensive
to also just do the the control of what
would happen then
but you know chances are that models are
going to improve significantly as well
if you simply provide a bigger data set
um
of of of these okay
so i yeah
it's it's questionable whether or not
this this modeling of the
reward here is really the deal breaker
or simply the fact that they
have collected much more and much higher
quality
data to train on and then the reward
model is simply
the proxy for that data so that's the
that's the first kind of um
dent here that's not really clear now
oh don't get me wrong this paper is
pretty awesome especially because they
evaluate
all the summaries using humans as well
and that costs a lot too
so regardless of training even
evaluating these summaries in terms of
not
rouge but actual human feedback is very
expensive and they do this
as well and this is
this is of course pretty pretty awesome
and gives you the most accurate signal
that alone is commendable but i don't i
don't
believe yet that this reward modeling is
the
thing that made the improvement here in
their training procedure
the second thing is they do the
following their
reward for the ppo algorithm isn't
actually
just the reward from the reward model as
you can see here
but it has this kl term in here so what
does this kl
term do so here is
the this is the supervised baseline the
supervised baseline is simply a model
that as we said was trained
to input it post and output one of the
summaries that the humans provided
this thing right here is the
reinforcement learned baseline so this
is the thing that's actively changing
during ppo
okay so and you constrain
this to be to stay close to the
um to the supervised baseline
so you don't want your you don't want
your reinforcement learned model to go
far away from the supervised
baseline model so in terms of the reward
your reward is going to be
um the reward that you get from
the reward model that is trying to
predict
how good humans like the particular
thing
uh minus a penalty so
mine is a penalty term if you are
too far away from the supervised
baseline
and this should remind you of something
so you're kind of trying to optimize
the you're trying to especially if you
look at the diagram
of the model right because you have a
piece of text right and then you have
your model right here that you train and
then you have
the output summary okay and then you
have the reward model
and you have the reward as an output
that you're trying to make as big as
possible
now what does that remind you of if you
look at this model right here you're
trying to you're trying to
optimize its input right this is the
input to that model
in order to make its output a certain
way
while all the while making the input be
not too far away from some reference
input
this should remind you of adversarial
examples all right
because what's happening right here is
exactly
we are trying to find an adversarial
example to
the reward model okay
it's it's not adversarial in the sense
that it tries to maximize its loss or
something like this
but it is trying to maximize its output
its reward
and it's trying to manipulate the input
to the reward model such that the reward
is as high as possible
and what do we know about adversarial
examples
um is that they aren't really
really part of the normal data spectrum
if you will so and we're going to
see this and they have this they have
this
problem as well so if they
uh constrain they
there is a parameter there where you can
trade off how close you want to stay
so how much freedom do you give the
reinforcement learning to go away from
the supervised baseline
and you can clearly see that here is the
fraction
preferred by humans and here is this
this kl
if you optimize with reinforcement
learning
and you let the reinforcement learning
you know you give it some room
the more to the right here the more
freedom the reinforcement learning model
has
you can see that it goes up and up but
after a certain while
it is flat and actually goes down again
so if you purely reinforcement learn
what you really find are adversarial
examples to the reward model
that have nothing to do with the humans
anymore
because it's really just an adversarial
example
and to demonstrate this they have this
nice piece in the appendix
where they give samples from these
over-optimized policies so policies that
are just
over-optimized to this reward model
so here and we don't see the piece of
text
which i find is also interesting because
here
we are just um the reader of the paper
can is just tasked with judging without
i think without finding the piece of
text without reading the piece of text
which is interesting that humans can
actually do this
makes you kind of think of how it all
works but
so here the reference summary that a
human wrote was i'm 28 may
live in san jose i would like to learn
how to do
gymnastics okay um 20 or
year old dudes stubbornly post ponies
start
pursuing gymnastics hobby citing
logistics reason despite obvious
interest question or question my
question mark
um it so yeah
negatively affecting long-term fitness
progress personally
it just seems like a bunch of it just
seems like these websites that people
made to rank high on google because it
has all the terms
that make google happy which i mean this
something like this is exactly happening
here right you just
trying to fit everything in there to
make the reward model happy the reward
model
was only ever trained on
let's say coherent summaries textual
summaries
so if you go away from this data
manifold
you can find things that score high but
that
a human wouldn't rate high that's simply
because the reward model isn't
you know it's all isn't all knowing it's
simply a neural network
and they are susceptible to adversarial
examples
left password saved on work computer
replacement spends every hour
of the day watching netflix uh employees
stubbornly postponing his replacement
so it uh if by trying reasonable
question or question or question
negatively affecting productivity you
can already see
um that there is some sort of a
pattern here negatively affected
um so this this
this policy simply finds like this
structure of text um
stubbornly postponies that seems to make
the reward model
very very very happy but
it really goes away from
the text right here i get it's pretty
cool actually
because you see my fridge and that it
kind of copies over the words in what it
already knows it makes sense
and i think this ties a lot into what
i've been saying about how gpt3 works
because this is kind of a really dumbed
down version of gpd3 it's actually the
same architecture
and you can pretty clearly see that what
it does is interpolate different
things so in this case it interpolates
what it knows makes the reward model
happy which seems to be this
phrase right here and it interpolates
the kind of important words
from the text on the left a little bit
so um it sort of understands what
makes the reward model happy and thereby
you can already see
how a reward model like this may
work in that it will sort of
judge the it will judge whether or not
some of the words are present right here
and that's
100 percent due to the reward model i
think not being trained
on you know sentences like what we've
just seen
because even the supervised baseline the
summaries are going to be pretty okay
and the
especially the human reference summaries
are going to be pretty okay
for the most part they're going to
already be coherent they're going to be
linked linguistically
correct grammatically correct and so on
so
it just never seen that space of data
right if we scroll back through the
this giant mess right here this is
already um it's already the
paper basically so after implementing
this particular
reward you can see that they now have a
handle
right here on how much the rl is
supposed to go away from the supervised
baseline
if they simply constrain this to some
reasonable degree
then um the reinforcement learning seems
to improve
the uh seems to improve
the summaries okay so the results here
are you've already seen i think the main
results
in that they are pretty pretty good
especially you can see this in they also
ask the humans to rate
summaries in different uh kind of in
different areas
and you can see that the reference
summaries are always
or most of the time better than the
supervised baseline and also the
pre-trained only models
yet the human feedback models
they outperform the reference summaries
which is
you know it's pretty cool because you'd
think that humans
would be sort of very good at this stuff
but the human feedback you can think of
it
as kind of emulating an ensemble of
humans
so the reference summary is just a
single human writing a summary
and the human feedback is optimizing a
model that kind of
tries to integrate all of the human
summaries that exist
from a particular of a particular post
of course it would be interesting to see
of how diverse
the how diverse the summaries would be
i believe they they have some experiment
where they sample with different
temperatures but still maybe there's
trade-off with diversity here that it
always goes for the best one
and um they make do a lot of experiments
i don't want to actually get into
they also transfer this to this news
data set
so simply trained on reddit but then
transfer it to the news data set
which it works pretty well as you can
see right here
so it works almost as well as a
supervised baseline that was directly
trained on that data set
and that's fairly fairly cool
so i definitely think that there is a
a value and the criticism of rouge
definitely is warranted um also the
question of how we train
with different with things such as
summary where we can't even really
formulate what we want like there's a
trade-off with length as well
um the incorporation of human feedback
is very
valuable so the last part they do is
understanding
the reward model they ask themselves
what
what does the reward model actually
learn and this is where i'm
a little bit disappointed
in here though this this is very
valuable right the
fact that um they
show that if you let it go too far if
you optimize only for the reward model
you fail they also do investigations
into model size
and how much data you need and so on
they change
a little bit the things which i this
okay this this is pretty cool where they
say we construct an additional
validation set by having labelers make
minimal edits to summaries to improve
them
our reward model our reward models
prefer
the edited summaries almost as often
as a separate set of human evaluators so
the reward models can sort of
spot when summaries improve and so on
they do a lot of
validating that the reward models are
actually in line with human preferences
however
as we see if you directly optimize for
the reward model
if you are allowed to go away from the
data manifold of valid summaries
then anything can happen and that's the
danger with incorporating reinforcement
learning
right here you can also see they're
clearly better than humans so here
are the these curve that i draw at the
beginning for these reward models
whereas the rouge as you can see it just
flattens out
after a certain complexity
um what they don't investigate what
would be really interesting
um is just something
that i would find interesting is how
much the reward model
actually depends on the input post
because it seems like it seems like
you could you know trade off information
in the input post and coherence and so
on
by looking at what happens if you
actually change the input post does it
matter a lot
how much does it matter and so on so
this it would be fairly cool to look at
especially given that
we humans can apparently look at these
summaries and judge them fairly well
by just looking at the summaries of
course we have no clue what the article
said uh yeah
all right so here they discussed some
limitations
and they're of course very very open
about the limitations right here
you know it's extremely skill intensive
time consuming to produce good ones and
expensive
so yeah the last thing here is the
broader impact statement and they
of course go through the uh full
trifecta of broader impact statements
which again to repeat
so you have to you have to do this you
have to so here is you and
you you take you take your hand
and you go like you know that the
catholics go you touch here you touch
here you touch here
or the shoulders here and here and
you say the magic words the magic words
are
technology good technology bad
technology biased
okay so what you want to do is
it's technology which is a metaphor that
broader impact statements they never
actually deal with the exact method in
the paper they always go
like up one layer or two and of course
the extreme is
technology so you don't want to talk bad
about your technique because my god
your technique isn't bad is it um so you
just go up and you say
whatever language models can be bad or
good or
machine learning can be better or
technology now first you say
it's a it's good right so
many potential positive effects of
aligning machine learning algorithms
with the designer's preferences
and um again i think this is a bit
overhyped this aligning because we
clearly see
that the way they do it if you align too
much
it is misaligned again ironically
then bad so unfortunately
our techniques also enable malicious
actors to more easily train models that
cause societal harm
yes that's the technology bad part
and you can see for instance one could
use human feedback to fine-tune a
language model to be more persuasive and
manipulate humans beliefs
so we're talking about language models
we're not talking about
e-summarization
here in this particular case we're
talking about language models
so that's the technology part and then
technology bias so you can pretty
clearly
um predict that there's going to be a
part
that is something like there you go
however since the data set consists of
user submitted posts with minimal
moderation they often contain contents
if
offensive reflect harmful societal
biases
this means our models can generate
biases or offensive summaries
as they have been trained to summarize
such content
at least this is actually about you know
summarization
at least this is actually about the
model in question right here
so props to that but
if you ever write a broader impact
statement the
the uh holy trifecta of broader impact
statements
must apply and you're good all right
that was my thoughts
for this paper a bit of rambling look at
the
paper look at the appendix look at the
code that they've released i
believe they've even released this small
model they have a one billion parameter
model
i don't want to promise too much but
yeah they have a lot of appendix a lot
of experiments right there
and check out openai with that
that was it for me bye-bye